an appropriate question on the show this
week how do we heat our homes in a
climate-friendly way hydrogen or
electricity the debates well heating up
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap this week we're in
Ellesmere Port beside as you can see
this huge Refinery a symbol of our
fossil fuel past well and present too
but just around the corner is a
neighborhood that could be pointing the
way to a cleaner future still based on
gas but hydrogen gas but as we'll see
not everyone's happy
and also in the show
as the cold snap forces Britain into
using Coal Power stations this week are
we really close to becoming coal-free
and we'll hear from the trailblazing
woman training young Africans in Green
Tech
but first to a corner of Cheshire that's
becoming a test bed for the move from
natural gas to hydrogen are the
residents happy to be guinea pigs and is
hydrogen appropriate for homes anyway
let's find out
this is stanlow Refinery it produces
billions of liters of petrol Diesel and
jet fuel a year and the idea is to
retool this place to produce hydrogen as
well because some hope hydrogen can
replace natural gas as the standard fuel
in our homes
what do you use gas for in your home
it's about everything eating cooking hot
water how important is it it's essential
I can't live without it especially in
this weather
three quarters of homes in the UK are
dependent on gas for heating but when
it's burnt it releases carbon dioxide
decarbonizing our homes is essential if
we're going to reach Net Zero
natural gas is methane its chemical
formula is CH4 the C is carbon hydrogen
gas is just H2 there is no carbon given
that hydrogen can run in pipes boilers
and cookers some people think it's
almost an oven ready replacement for gas
there will be no chain for people who
are currently used for using natural gas
the housing stock will be populated with
what are known as hydrogen ready boilers
so that is a boiler that can use natural
gas currently and at the point of
conversion can be converted into situ in
someone's home and according to uh the
government will be thrown in under two
hours and then they just are using
natural gas in this using hydrogen in
the same way as they're using natural
gas
to test that idea a so-called hydrogen
Village is proposed just around the
corner from that big Refinery complete
with a hydrogen experience Center to
show people how hydrogen works in the
home previous projects have shown that
only small changes are needed to gas
pipes and our homes in order to start
using this more sustainable gas
what do the residents think well some of
them are not too Keen
I think is ridiculous hydrogen with all
the risk reduction measures will still
result in three times as many fires or
explosions in the house natural gas the
consensus of independent analysts is the
hydrogen will be at least two to five
times the price of natural gas dependent
on the manufacturing method and it's too
inefficient Keith and many other
residents are unhappy The Proposal is
for around 2 000 homes in this area to
be cut off from natural gas
are you being a bit of a stick in the
mud I don't think so no our homes our
properties our families have been
offered on a plate to the oil and gas
industry to experiment in many locals
here resent being part of what they see
as an imposed real world experiment
but Cadence who are running the trial
told us they will continue to engage
with residents
I've had several hundred people
contacted me to say that they are
against it I've had a few people contact
me to say they're in favor of it and of
course we know that actually there's
about 2 000 homes affected so there are
a large number of people in the middle
who haven't spoken up at all
this unease about using hydrogen in our
homes is not just local nimbyism many
energy experts think home energy is just
not a smart use of hydrogen the only low
carbon zero carbon form of hydrogen is
green hydrogen and that's made from
electricity and you need an awful lot of
electricity to make green hydrogen and
then turn that back into heat in a
hydrogen boiler when you compare that to
other options you know where you use the
electricity directly rather than
converting it to hydrogen and back into
heat using a heat pump you're actually
getting a much higher efficiency and
you're saving yourself an awful lot of
that energy that you need for the
hydrogen root
heat pumps use electricity to draw air
from the outside and turn it into warm
air for your home
here in Worcestershire they're being
fitted to a new development of 55 homes
with no connection to the gas grid gotta
face the fact that we've all got to try
to be more ecologically friendly and
we've got to try to reduce the costs of
running our houses and Etc so the whole
package of great insulation a modern
heating system is obviously going to
mean that we can sell the house if we
ever need to much quicker than if we're
selling it with a gas boiler
these heat pumps are going into new
homes retrofitting them is often more
disruptive than switching from natural
gas to hydrogen that is one of the main
arguments from the gas Network company
cadent who run the hydrogen experience
center with British gas
they decided late on not to speak to us
but home hydrogen still has its
supporters the efficiency argument is
important Tom we can't argue with that
but it's not the only Factor that's
important what's important is the
overall economic cost and importantly
the cost of consumer in all this but
Cadence run some of the gas network
British gas is a gas company it's in
their interest to back hydrogen well not
at all Tom the members of my trade
Association make heat pumps or make heat
interface units for heat networks and
then make hydrogen ready boils and
currently gas boilers so for many of our
members actually making a heat pump you
know if that's what they have to do
they're manufacturers that's what
they'll do but to suggest that we're
only interested in this because
um you know it's in our financial
commercial interest it's absolutely the
wrong thing gas is a key part of our
home energy ecosystem making a clean
break is painful
I've returned from Ellesmere port and
I'm in Sky News kind of energy switching
Center this is really the nerve center
of electricity for this place and I'm
with David joffe from the climate change
committee which advises government on
policy in this area
David simple question in a way hydrogen
right for homes or not right for homes
our assessment is that
using a lot of hydrogen for homes is not
going to work because we simply won't
have enough energy that we can produce
in the UK we're going to be very import
dependent if we use a lot of hydrogen
and that won't be good for us it will be
expensive as well when you say a lot I
mean are you really saying that there
might be a tiny minority of houses but
on the whole no is that more or less it
our position is that wherever you can
use electrified solutions that includes
heat pumps but not limited to heat pumps
that's the best thing to do and then
where you can't do that where that's not
feasible whether it's too expensive then
yes we could use hydrogen but you've had
a report out this week that's looked at
energy Supply where do you see hydrogen
fitting in so used for a variety of
things and it is an important solution
it is an important part of Net Zero we
just shouldn't be trying to do
everything with it so what we need to
use it for is low carbon industry to
decarbonize that we think there's a
really important role for that for
example high temperature heat in
Industry where there's very few ways of
doing that in a low carbon way so things
like steel but other things as well like
steel but other things as well
Ceramics for example those sorts of
things where we need high temperatures
so that's an important thing also a
really important role in backing up our
renewable based electricity system so we
we're going to need to have an
electricity system that's fully
decarbonized by 2035 using a range of
Technologies but mostly in terms of
electricity generation things like
offshore wind like solar generation
onshore wind and nuclear now there'll be
times when the wind isn't blowing that
much and we'll need to fill in those
gaps and hydrogen-fired power stations
is a good way of doing that so we think
that's an important solution so when the
wind is blowing a lot we're not using a
lot of energy actually in our homes and
businesses you make hydrogen then yes
basically and then put it in some kind
of storage tank some kind of compression
absolutely so we think that as you say
there will be times where there are
surpluses of wind generation we can
produce the hydrogen then we can store
it in things called salt Caverns which
are geological uh facilities to store
the hydrogen and we can take it out when
we need it put it back through a power
plant and generate the electricity when
we need it what about the government's
performance overall on on decarbonizing
its electricity our power generation
system uh not really quite going fast
enough not up to speed we've reduced
emissions from electricity Generation by
70 over the last decade that's really
good but looking forward we need to be
building the storage facilities of
electricity storage and hydrogen storage
we need to be expanding the network the
electricity transmission and building
new hydrogen pipelines and those bits
are not going fast enough so not on
target to hit our targets for 2035 not
yet no we still think it's within reach
and we made the recommendation to for
the 2035 date in 2020 the government
accepted it in 2021 but that's 18 months
ago and we haven't yet seen a plan from
the government about how the overall
2035 Target is going to be achieved
thanks very much indeed Dave well this
week did see the unwelcome return of
something from our fossil fuel past and
that was the switching on of a
coal-fired power station for the first
time this winter because of a cold snap
so while this does raise some questions
about our ability to get off coal Simon
Evans from carbon brief tells us it's
not all bad news
I'm Dr Simon Evans the senior policy
editor at Carbon Reef earlier this week
we published new analysis showing that
UK greenhouse gas emissions of 3.4 lower
in 2022 than a year earlier thanks to
above average temperatures and a surging
clean energy that means that the UK's
emissions are now 49 below 1990 levels
in other words halfway to meeting the
target of Net Zero by 2050. now one of
the most striking findings around in our
analysis was that UK coal use fell by
another 15 last year in fact it's now
solo it's the lowest it's been since
1757 266 years ago in 1757 King George
II was on the throne and Mozart was
still in nappies I think that's really
interesting finding because it's
actually completely contrary to a lot of
the headlines we've been seeing over the
past year about the UK turning back to
coal in in light of the global energy
crisis in fact nothing could be further
from the truth our analysis shows that
far from turning back to Coal the UK is
turning away from coal so hard it's the
lowest it's been since before the
Industrial Revolution the only problem
with this is that we've cut coal so
quickly and that's one of the reasons
why UK missions have fallen so fast over
the past decade but there's now hardly
any coal left to cut
if the UK wants to meet its Target of
Net Zero by 2050 that means it now has
to turn Beyond coal and start cutting
emissions from oil and gas as well
now to a place where the progress to a
decarbonized future is pretty much
unarguable and that's the town of
sonderberg in Denmark they've done so
well in decarbonizing that the
International Energy agency has called
them the Energy Efficiency capital of
the world well here's Brian seberg from
their project zero to tell us how
they've done it
[Music]
my name is Brian seberg I'm the CEO of
project zero this is my city
this is the city of Cinnabon located in
the southern part of Denmark today I
will show you why my city is named the
global capital of Energy Efficiency
just have a look at this Supermarket it
helps us to save a lot of energy by
reusing excess heat from cooling this
place and freezers and they are selling
excess heat to homes and companies
through the Local District housing group
so we are sharing we're producing
electricity and then we are converting
it to heat we are converting it to Fuels
in a sustainable Manner and in an
inefficient manner
one of the ways we do that for instance
to provide heat is with heat pumps and
that is not only to heat our house but
it could be high temperature heat for
processes in Industries
[Music]
[Applause]
Danvers has been one of the main
businesses in the region contributing to
project zero with technology and
solutions to reduce energy demand and to
reuse energy already produced
The Factory side has now become a part
of the Local District heating grid
providing lower energy prices for the
local community in Solo ball we reuse
excess heat from data Savers to heat our
homes and Office Space
carbon emission from space Heating and
hot domestic water have been reduced by
73 percent
the work is a pretty inspiring place
when you look at our settlements here it
shows you how far we have to go to
approach those levels of Energy
Efficiency now coming up after the break
as the world marked International
women's day this week we hear from the
inspiring leader who's training young
African women to get into Green Tech I
speak to one of the UK's negotiators
involved in agreeing a defining new
treaty to protect our oceans
and shopping in the endangered aisle how
climate change could threaten some of
our Supermarket Staples
[Music]
welcome back to the show
well to Mark International women's day
that was earlier this week we've got a
great film for a woman who's helping
other women while also fighting the
climate crisis Astria fataki sent us
this from Togo
hi I'm Ashley
founder of every generation energy
generation is a fun African organization
that is based in Lumi Togo and that aims
to train young Africans and especially
young women to become entrepreneurs in
the field of clean energy Healthcare and
agribusiness and I said especially young
women because when I founded energy
generation seven years ago I did it
because I wanted to contribute to
changing The Narrative of the continent
and as I move along in this journey I
realized that women were actually the
best Storyteller to tell the story of
this beautiful and vibrant continent but
of course not only telling the story
also writing it a woman or powerful
change maker in their ecosystem and yet
they are not always valued as much as
they should be there have been some
improvements that there is still so much
to do and for me one of the key ways to
empower women so that they can write the
story the new story of the continent and
build the future of the continent is to
empower them through education
Port by giving them the tools so that
they can become the
hero of Their Own Story because they do
have the potential to do so
foreign
news of a new international treaty being
agreed to protect a large proportion of
What's called the high seas that's the
bit outside of national jurisdiction and
it could be very very important for our
marine life and I'm joined by Alan Evans
who was at the heart of the UK team Alan
why is this important it truly was a
momentous moment in the governance of
the world's ocean what the new treaty is
now providing is some measures there's
some a framework that now enables states
to actually establish for example Marine
protected areas Beyond areas of national
jurisdiction it provides them with a
government structure that will enable
them to regulate better should any
industry move offshore into areas of the
high sea well this is quite interesting
you mentioned interesting because one of
the things I've heard is this is partly
about the genetic resources of what lies
on the seabed I mean I think people
talked about some of the creatures there
being relevant in some of the drugs we
produce and in the future we need to
protect them make sure the right people
get rewarded and the creatures
themselves get protected is this the
kind of thing what the new treating now
provides is
a mechanism where any monetary benefits
that could be recognized through the
exploitation of marine genetic resources
collected in the high seas that that
revenue is now shared equally with the
greater good with okay other member
states so if I'm a company that finds I
don't know some some sponge or some you
know jellyfishes provides the the cure
for something or other that makes me
billions I've got to share that out in
in the International Goods that's
correct yes because no state has
Sovereign rights to the resources of the
high seas until now where all states
effectively have part ownership so what
did the agreement moment feel like
truly momentous I mean it had been you
know a tough tough four and a half years
of negotiating but it was the end of a
journey which took two four and a half
years to get there and the last two
weeks was you know in particular very
intense yeah a great sense of joy and
relief at the end
um is it just about if you like genetic
resources or could it help to actually
protect you know fisheries and wildlife
more widely in the ocean it certainly
can help protect I mean the ability now
to establish Marine protected areas that
there is a Target by many to establish
30 of the world ocean as protected areas
by 2013. now that is a big ask and this
helps with that does it this certainly
helps with that how will it be policed
or enforced if you like the details of
how that will be done are yet to be
determined but there will be a need for
the use of you know Innovative
Technologies to to make sure tracking
vessels and things like that absolutely
yeah yeah I mean this already happens
for where areas within national
jurisdiction on you know in vast ocean
areas have already been established this
already happens we often hear about the
Seas being in Peril and we've got the
ocean rescue here are the oceans now
better protected after this agreement
most certainly I mean
given the ability to establish more
protected areas given the ability into
the new treaty to ensure that should new
industries develop offshore there is an
environmental impact assessment process
now and should that eia show that there
might be some damage to the marine
environment through whatever activity is
being proposed well States will have a
right to stop that activity taking place
thanks very much Alan now to a
supermarket like no other we've been
shopping in the endangered aisle as the
Fair Trade Organization says that many
of the products we love could be in
Peril at a time of climate change
foreign
[Music]
you see empty shelves and those shelves
could be very much what we could see in
the future if we don't act now and we've
already been seeing it recently with the
shelves and supermarkets being empty the
salad products well it's a very real
fact that if we carry on like this in
the future we might not see cocoa
bananas and coffee on the shelves
[Music]
almost half of the banana Imports that
come into the UK come from countries
where there are devastating climate
challenges happening such as floods such
as droughts hurricanes and really high
temperatures
90 of coffee farmers are saying that
they are already being severely impacted
by climate change
my name is
I am a small holder farmer from
Uganda on the slopes of a great Mountain
on telephone
we are growing uh coffee
but the the volumes are under threat
because of climate change
the coffee I grow has migrated
from the attitude to use to grow and
it's going up in search of
temperatures
where it can survive leaving the farmers
invulnerable with very very struggling
coffee
incomes alone from coffee are not enough
to to help us adapt and to confront this
planet monster
[Music]
I want to be able to help and support So
by making a small change they can
protect the future of the food and be
not paying too high prices or to empty
shelves in the future
a great illustration there how both
farmers and consumers are impacted by
climate change but also how we might
have to adapt to it now just a reminder
that you can catch up with the daily
climate show weekdays on Sky News at 3
30.
and you can also get all the latest
climate and environmental news on the
Sky News website or app or by scanning
the QR code on your screen right now
that's it from Cheshire see you for the
show again next week
foreign